[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
myself
we have a special podcast today we have
the Hodge twins and they tell me when
they walked in I looked at their beard I
mean it's very hard to tell them apart
they say the ladies can tell them apart
so if you're watching this let us know
who's Keith who's Kevin who's sitting on
the left or right and we'll be watching
through the commentary to see if you
have any idea of Who's Who if you don't
know who they are their social media
phenomenons they've been for a long time
they have a YouTube channel with a two
and a half million subscribers former
Marines they're professional I mean how
should I put this in a diplomatic way
professional [ __ ] talks I was just gonna
go with that [ __ ] it's not entertaining
but here's the other part there's a
difference between [ __ ] talk and but
sometimes talking trash to the point
where you make the audience think and
say that kind of makes sense you know so
there's a different aspect to it where
it's just purely entertainment purposes
the other aspect is also uh uh wanting
to get some people to think interesting
story about these guys obviously they're
twins but they've both been married for
15 years I want to say
20 20 years 22 years and one of you has
four kids one he has three unless if
it's changed right yeah just three for
me not to my knowledge
I might have a couple like that okay
Adam's kind of a guy anyways okay so
look we got a lot of things to cover
obviously we'll get into it here in a
minute but let me kind of uh preface
what topics we're going to cover after
we learn more about them at the
beginning uh there's stuff that happened
in Iran I want to talk about something
happened with ladies in Iran who are
cutting their hairs as a form of
protesting against the hijab and the
morality police you should have seen
what happened just a couple days ago I
want to talk about that Armenia what
happened with Armenia against Azerbaijan
that's been a pretty interesting uh
events taking place there were Nancy
Pelosi went and paid a visit uh uh to
Armenia it's not a good situation
Azerbaijan is purely bullying and a
member to Parliament imagine like a head
of state getting up and reminding The
Armenian when I played this video for
you and you hear what this man said it's
going to be very very disturbing we had
a massive crisis folks take place
in Martha's Vineyard I mean it's tragic
events that these folks there's two
million people crossing the southern
border but God forbid if 50 are sent to
Martha's Vineyard they have to call then
they would have to call Tyler that's a
Kahu they called the army they called
National Guard I think it was 125
National Guards for 50 immigrants they
called the National Guard for 50
immigrants I mean obviously I'm sure you
guys got something to say about that
Newsom the other day called out the
santis for debate and I like uh the
Santa's rebottle back then we'll get
some commentary on that and then
Kardashian had a uh a meeting a sit down
with uh 2021 Forbes Woman of the Year
Hillary Clinton I don't know if you guys
are familiar with her uh they had a sit
down with her and Kardashian they had a
legal quiz going back and forth which
was interesting and then we got a few
other stories that we'll cover as well
but aside from that my sister bought
this magazine yesterday we'll just do a
little bit of trivia and have fun with
this okay she bought this magazine yes
today she comes at a house where playing
dominoes Dylan again is back at it at
eight years old just kicking everyone's
butt although Paula they won yesterday
and it shows her estate and I want to
ask you guys this try to play along
without Googling this and messing it up
but Adam I'm going to ask you and Kevin
Keith I'm gonna ask you guys as well
here in a minute on she had a big stamp
collection okay on how much you think
that was worth she had a big car
collection real estate portfolio on how
big it was her horse
racing value her royal collection of art
what that's worth but here's the one I
really got a question I want to ask you
guys is the crown jewels she wears this
crown jewels okay this is what it looks
like okay I don't know if you've seen
this or not Adam that's what it looks
like I want to know what you think that
alone is worth in a minute we'll go
through it but at this point
Keith Kevin uh for folks who don't know
your background first of all thanks for
coming out take right off the bat just
tell us a little bit about your story
how it came about to you guys becoming
you know YouTube phenomenons today where
everyone's wanting to learn more about
you guys well it uh it started back in
2012. now 2010 2010. yeah it was
actually uh we just uh we wanted to be
CPA's accountants yeah but we had this
job where we was insurance adjusters
right you mean serious right now you're
joking yeah I'm serious we work for AAA
of Southern California yeah who the hell
wants to get into insurance by the way
auto accidents and I came across YouTube
YouTube was in this infancy at the time
and I went to council let these people
on YouTube let's uh let's start doing
videos we can uh we can be comedians
literally yeah he came to my cubicle
which his cubicles right on across the
mind he walks around and tells me I said
what are you talking about though it's
gonna be a Certified Public Accounts
yeah now let me ask you while you're
doing that did you did a video prompt
you going to him or no like did you see
something and say dude we can do better
than these guys yeah I don't know we saw
videos so look at all these views these
people getting these people are whack
this is okay this is pride you know yeah
so uh we started doing the videos but we
was having a hard time finding the time
to do it because we had full-time jobs
at Triple A so we came up with a great
idea on our lunch break at work we can
go into the uh second floor there's a
conference room with no signage or
anything which gets the empty four it
was vacant so we would do our videos now
somehow another HR found out that we're
doing videos in there
you forget how they found out they was
investigating this one guy right because
he was passed up for promotion so we had
did some videos with them so when he
went to his YouTube channel and he saw
him talking trash about the company
right there's me and keeping several of
his videos yeah so what happened was the
HR at the time I remember the economy it
Tanked
we was it was totally overstepped this
is 10 2010. this was yeah it was around
2011 or so yeah so we're totally
overstaffed so I remember me and Keith
was coming back from lunch and we saw HR
right I was like whenever you see hr's
like oh [ __ ] somebody's gonna get fired
yeah yeah it was this ball guy ball
white guy right and he was apparently
reminiscent of what we got going on over
here right just shout out to Robert
O'Rourke and he was obviously not
doesn't not that it matters he was
obviously gay he was the gay guy we got
the same situation
we're coming back from lunch and Joe's
like look hey Charles here they're gonna
fire somebody and right before they
walked in the building they stopped and
looked at us
and then they walk but I guess like why
the [ __ ] are they looking at us like
that
[ __ ] you not I sit down I'll clock back
in excuse me Keith um we have to see you
know in the conference room
tell this you're getting out of order we
[ __ ] you up so so we sit down right
I'm at my cubicle and then the uh I
remember the managers out of office the
assistant manager came up said Hey Kevin
um we need to talk to you for a moment I
was like oh okay I totally forgot about
it Joe so I'm sitting down right
and I said oh [ __ ] there's the the bald
white gay guy so we sit down he's got a
female with him and he start asking me
questions like loaded questions like
questions they already know the answer
to and I was like uh this is this about
the YouTube videos I'm doing I said yeah
I do videos but I don't say where I'm at
there's no signage nobody knows where
I'm at I don't even tell people where I
work at what's the promise of well you
use some foul language I say y'all
calling me over some foul language of a
video that nobody knows where I'm at and
it's during my lunch break when I'm off
the clock so I lost it
was so demand you would come in in the
mornings on Monday your queue was full
of uh claims I'm on the phone all day
constantly you have no time to take a
break and I was like pissed I'm like oh
I come in here every day I bust my ass I
don't make any problems or anything and
you talk to me about some YouTube videos
some foul language that nobody heard I
mean so they was put me on a minute not
that any one of them go and take off or
not yet you guys haven't taken off yet
okay got it so it's not like one got two
million viewers and they're like hey
right everyone's calling me it was like
1500 views man it was got it yeah yeah
so uh we getting uh like verbal
altercation they call security and all
that they escort me out before they
escort Miata say hey he's with my twin
brother I know if you talking to me you
gotta talk to my twin brother I said
where's Keith I went to his cubicle he's
not there they all regret his ass so I'm
walking all over the floor Hey where's
my [ __ ] brother right so I'm like
going all the empty rooms hey hey chief
over here hey hey Larry keep going here
it did us again but I don't know nothing
so I finally keep he's in the conference
room sitting down with HR it was funny
when I was not talking it was asking me
all these loaded questions I was like
yeah and then all of a sudden the door
busts open there you are these
[ __ ] fit in the fine
well you were hiding out where were you
at yeah I was in another conference room
on the other side of the building being
interrogated or just just hanging out by
the game guy with the insurance yeah
yeah this guy's making moves so I looked
at Kevin and did um the dead lost total
control of the situation and uh they
called security
and we went back to our desk like pack
up our things and it was a lot of people
people were actually crying because we
had been there for like yeah like three
or four years we like really friendly
guys with everybody knew it oh you've
been working there for a while oh yeah
okay wow yeah so I'm in my um
a couple of secretaries down I always
used to talk to them they were they were
upset they were crying and it was just
and it was a horrible situation because
at the time when I got fired my wife was
eight and a half months pregnant
right and I was like so he was worried
about the insurance thing and whatnot
and my wife was like get a real job
YouTube's not a job so
not at the time for sure yeah not at the
time but looking back on that was such a
blessing for that to happen to us
because yeah that gave us literally a
year of unemployment to see if we can
make YouTube work and it eventually did
and yeah we wasn't making money the
whole time like the money was earning
like 50 Cent 60 Cent okay for me two
dollars this month yeah way to go and
then you know it was on unemployment for
um I think 10 11 months and right before
we got
um off on unemployment we made partner
and we started earning a little money
and we kept doing it kept doing it but
by the time our unemployment ran out you
know was able to we wasn't making the
same amount and we was earning from AAA
but we was earning just enough to
survive yeah and we always wanted to be
like self-employed I never want to work
for anybody else again and I thought
this was a great opportunity to take
advantage of that and I never would have
thought it would uh took the route that
it did I had no idea I'll be here
sitting talking to like famous people
like you famous people famous rich
people like you if I was in a bank vault
he bought out Chase Bank
that's right
oh yeah so if if I was in high school
with you guys like if I'm in like 10th
grade who are you guys in high school I
was the shot's weirdest kid get out of
here we were loners yeah sir so this is
in Virginia this yeah you guys are
loners in high school yeah it was just
us you're not class clowns you're not
athletes you're not like we used to act
up but we're just always together you
lose each other's best friends but um it
was like we was just so shy and I was
like weird shy yeah socially I remember
I remember yeah socially awkward I
remember this is how weird we was as
kids after a basketball game we was in
junior high we was walking home right
yeah and these white girls put think was
after basketball practice no it's not
the game I think which one is it guys
get it together that's one of those
we're walking home right and these white
girls put up for my school hey Holly's
twins where y'all going
freaked out I took off
you didn't spit in the game you didn't
Hollow he just ran away I was just weird
man you know I wasn't gay or anything I
was just you know he's just he got but
hey 20 bucks is 20 bucks we're both of
you guys like that with the ladies yeah
he just left me dead and they're like
where's your brother going I was like I
don't know I'm gonna go Jordan
wow so no Sports no we we played Sports
yeah we played sports but uh as far as
like it was just like me and him that's
all we needed was each other we didn't
need friends who created that that that
for you guys to be closed which did a
parent play role in this or was it just
the two of you guys I think a lot of it
had to do because when we grew up we was
really really poor really poor I didn't
we didn't have nice clothes we didn't
have anything so we get stuck together
yeah so we stuck together because we
didn't want to get you know bullied for
that because we didn't I remember
confidence was low yeah self-confident
because where we live how poor we didn't
have food most times
so we just stuck together because we
didn't have a lot of self-confidence as
kids growing up because uh childhood was
so rough yeah everybody else was wearing
like uh Jordans and we're walking around
with USA 500s from the dollar store and
yeah like that and wrestler jeans
everybody had Jordan yeah it sucked our
first house that we live in when we was
kids that didn't even have a bathroom
had an outhouse
what year did you guys grow up in 1920
huh it's just us they're only four weeks
older than me
and you're using ouch at a birthday
yesterday or two days ago right you guys
just had a birthday yeah
so so so Mom Dad any what values were
injected like give us a painted picture
of what values were injected growing up
in the two of you guys was it hey you
got to work hard hey you gotta respect
people hey you know you got to read
books what what were some of the values
my my dad he worked two jobs he was a
barber and he worked at this um
at this uh took like it was Fieldcrest
it's like a textile mill and uh he was
never home because he always had two
jobs and my mom was like really
Christian and she always told us to do
the right thing and never do drugs or
you'll wind up like your cousin he's on
drugs and you don't want to be like damn
so but but my dad he worked really hard
actually one of his jobs eventually
killed him he caught some
um disease that has worked from
breathing in Cotton yeah and it killed
him how old were you guys he actually
died on my 14th birthday on your 14 how
did that affect you guys man it was
terrible it was it was rough yeah I mean
um it's been so long ago but
um and then I had an older brother who
went into the military so that was
somebody else to look up to and um
a lot of my friends looking back on it
didn't have no dads yeah
I didn't realize it at the time but all
my close friends all my close black
friends none of them they had a mom they
had a grandma yeah no dad I never
noticed any of that stuff but when I
looked back on it at least I had a dad I
think that's what kept us in line wow
because a lot of those guys stay uh
unfortunate for them they got locked up
you know and was there a relationship
with pops were you guys close four to 14
years like was there any kind of like
you played Sports together my daddy yeah
he's a big guy he wasn't mean well so he
didn't really that he didn't really talk
much the only time you saw Daddy's when
you [ __ ] up and he was beating your
ass and he would beat our ass oh man
like old school or no old school Daddy
was alive today doing this [ __ ] he'd be
locked up you can't do this
what's the running back that got in
trouble for whooping his kids uh oh and
uh Mike uh Peterson yeah he made
Peterson like the pope you know he got
knocked out last week by the way
Peterson did he voted against the Bell
uh
love you on Bill Le'Veon Bell was the
other running back yeah he knocked up
Peterson can we uh can we stay here on
this Dad concept yeah because we just
came back from Madrid we were
interviewing Andrew Tate I'm sure you're
familiar with him and a major focal
point of the interview was uh the role
of a father the role of a man the role
of uh what Andrew Tates that the
influence he had over him and his
brother the role that Pat's dad Gabriel
uh had over him and you said that your
dad passed away when you were 14 but he
was a badass dude would whoop your ass
all that yeah but you appreciated the
fact that at least you had a father
you're talking about the fact that all
your friends didn't even have a father
you'd even realize it yeah meaning it
was just completely normal in your
lifestyle right right and then when did
this Epiphany hit you and like what
happened to all your friends that didn't
have fathers I think this is something
that young men are lacking these days a
male influence a male figure leadership
go ahead you know what my dad really
didn't talk much but I saw what he did
each and every day that was a huge
influence for me what my dad had to go
through as far as working jobs and I
think that's very important for just men
in general because if you don't have a
father figure in your life you're going
to be like a woman actually if that's
who's raising you you're gonna be like
an angry woman yeah and women are
typically emotional and you don't want
your men to be emotional that's like a
that's like a nightmare for men yeah and
as far as my mom she really battled with
a lot of self-confidence because my mom
she grew up during Jim Crow so by the
time I was an adult when I was 18 I was
traumatized about white people being
racist because that's what she endured
when she was a grown up because she
actually lived through Jim Crow and all
that what would she what would she tell
you guys so hey Keith Kevin just make
sure when you're going on the streets
that when you go to school if the white
man what what were some of the mindsets
that were instilled in you with
specifically well my mama for the most
part was traumatized by racism
everything she looked at was through a
lens of black versus white because
that's what she experienced like Sam so
when when I graduate and I went to
school and when I went on to the
military I looked at white people
totally different than what I do now
because I heard all the horrors growing
up as a kid yeah I lost my father he
wasn't in my life but my mother's in my
life but what she instilled in US is
just fear of racism fear of racism like
fear of people judging you based on your
color okay I got it wasn't like hey son
in America you can do whatever you want
in your life as long as you do the work
and you read is that what she's saying
or no she's saying the opposite we had a
lot of experience with racism I remember
uh Keith was um uh he was spelling bee
he was in he was in a big time speller
you know so Keith he actually let me
tell us my story this is sixth grade I
was really I want I seen kids on TV
going through the spelling being winning
I was like I want to be that guy right
so I was sitting home
so I want to be that guy so I I remember
a spelling bee was announced she was
like yeah too much about something I'm
gonna enter this so I'm sitting home
just going over the list of words it's
gonna be um you know asked to spell and
I remember because like man you suck you
really want to be a spelling bee kid but
anyway I studied my ass off and um and
it came down to me and this white kid I
remember his name was Croy remember him
yeah yeah Croy Troy of Troy so that's my
Southern dialect coming through here
um Troy um
and they asked me they came to me and
said Spell almanac I remember to this
day I'll never hold up oh no I said
Almanac I got this one I know how to
spell this [ __ ] I said Almanac a l m a n
a c Almanac
right did she say I'm sorry you
misspelled it the correct spelling and
is this and I was like
no I've I spelled that correctly and
then it's like no and then she spelled
and I was like that's what I just said
yeah and then it escorted me off the
stage and the white kid won and I was so
pissed but I didn't realize it was
racism at the time I just thought I
messed up so I had this one teacher
named was Miss B she was a black teacher
she was the meanest woman nobody wanted
a class all the black students beat this
black woman in the world none of the
black students oh man you got Miss beef
oh my God she's the worst no black kid
wanted her and she was just straight and
she was black and she was real hard on
the black kids real hard yeah good way
or a bad way in a good way okay a black
girl showed up wait let me just let me
uh let me just hold on hold on no no no
no this morning there was this girl
named Sonora she showed up she had dark
red bright lipstick yeah she was a
dark-skinned girl Miss Drew actually
took her bent over knee and powdered her
and me to wipe up all the lipstick and
told her she'd like a prostitute
wow is your girl Miss B yeah Miss Drew
what was it Miss Drew Mr group Miss Drew
but anyway back before I was really
interrupted
by your brother yeah
after the spelling bee I was I was kind
of like in tears I was pissed all right
by the way you spelled it correctly no
you just put it correctly I saw Back to
the Future too I'm very familiar with
the other concept of the Almond right
you spelled it right right so I go to
miss Drew and she's crying
and she was like and that's the first
time she ever said anything nice to me
she's like I'm so proud of you right she
I was like but miss miss uh Drew I I
spelled the word correctly she said no
honey it's just some things you don't
understand right now
right yeah and uh she explained to us
like really
well this is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah now
the community you live in what's the
what's the split what percentage is
African-American what percentage is
white we actually grew up in a poor
white neighborhood we lived in a poor
black neighborhood before but then my
dad said let's go live with these poor
white people
[Laughter]
yeah so um we grew up in a poor white
neighborhood that's crazy perspective
right there by the way yeah
yeah to to see if you have a choose
between yeah crime you know all of that
versus the racism yeah father chose the
pain of having to deal with that over
yeah potentially losing your kids very
interesting and he actually said that
yeah yeah it was a lot safer I mean that
was a it was the West end of town where
all the black people lived in the city
and now they chose over there don't
forget Keith we got um after basketball
practice one day one of the teammates
sixth grade actually pulled a gun on me
and Keith yeah basketball and said give
me all your money I said man you robbing
the poorest black kid
this is a white kid or a black kid it's
a black kid
yeah they tried to Rob two broke ass
Brothers two black guys
I think I gave him a quarter
and I think I had a couple shiny red
pennies that's all he got yeah wow and
that was on the black side of town and
this kid was our age what was we 12 13.
he's only got it I think it was 10 11.
yeah and he put it right to our face and
robbers but the coach saw him yeah and
they called us in the school the next
day said what happened I said yeah
Michael pulled a gun on me and then he
and they said and then they expelled
them yeah funny thing is we went home we
was in military we went home we went to
the West End where we used to play
basketball just to reminisce and then we
saw the guy to pull a gun out of here
and he took off I said that was
Michael's get the hell out of he's
probably gonna come back and finish
that's like a white man can't jump right
I'm going to my car can I ask you guys a
question about this I think it's very
powerful we just said that you grew up
your mother was uh born and raised Jim
Crow dealing with all that you you were
raised amongst mostly black people you
moved to the Poor Side of Town all white
people what lessons did you learn about
Wipeout because your mother your mother
made you
very
scared of of white people I assume right
basically the lessons she was teaching
you yeah but here you are in a in a poor
area of white people right it's not like
these are privileged white people or
even like you know Blue Collar East
Coast racism white people these are
trailer Chargers I remember uh playing
with my friangle Mitch and his name he
came to one of my comedy shows but uh
every time we would be playing with them
when we come up and they start playing
with them all of a sudden he would have
to always go inside
right his mom didn't like us yeah his
mom didn't lie because I said hey man
why y'all keep going inside you know he
said oh my mom don't like [ __ ] said
this yeah damn he started laughing I
kind of started laughing too I was like
you don't say because my mom already
knew she already told me yeah that's why
they're doing it yeah yeah so so what
what what happened so from this
upbringing that you have extreme which
in a way I know it's gonna sound weird
but you have the best of uh you have the
worst of Both Worlds right yeah you have
the one side to see what it really looks
like and then the other side is what
racism looks like so then you guys join
do you guys join the Marines at the same
time or yeah yeah you guys go to the
same unit same everything is the same
MOS or no was it different no it's not
different we got lit up they didn't uh
our recruiter thought it'd be a bad idea
two identical twins but the Marine Corps
at the same time yeah so we went in like
three weeks apart yeah and then not the
same unit or same base
Third Battalion we're at per salad per
salad oh so same same uh base but just
not the same unit right which kind of
you still had a chance to have fun
together though I mean not not hardly so
not Marine
so was it active or was it were you uh
and then where did you go to after boot
camp I went to San Diego Kevin Went to
Tustin yeah MCS testing it's an old
airwayne they they closed down when I
was getting up I remember George Bush
was closing down a bunch of bases we
went from MCS testing to MCS El Toro
then he took El Toro to uh I think it
was um MCS Miramar in San Diego at what
point are you guys like at this point
politics what role does politics play in
your life at 18 years ago going into
boot camp about all Republicans was
racist I thought all white people was
racist yeah um I was raised to be a
Democrat my mom always uh taught us to
see look Democrats are for blacks
Republicans or for whites you know she
taught me that from as young as I can
remember like five six seven years old I
remember was watching the debate and
then she always
up and down she couldn't stand a
republican yeah what was the reasoning
because she linked Republicans to racism
is that kind of she was very naive when
it came to politics mommy had no idea
that Jim Crow was about Democrats she
had no idea that the KKK was started by
the Democrats she had no idea my mom was
a good woman but she ain't no [ __ ] about
polish yeah that's a lot of ours though
right I mean if you look at a lot of our
you know who raises us they don't they
don't sit there and go so what event
caused you guys to get a little bit more
into it and get interested was it this
insurance job that you guys had with her
right I would say it's my older brother
um he was a republican he used to put
things in my ear but I just thought he
was an Uncle Tom at the time yeah you
know I just I think over time as you
like live your life and you have
experience of uh other people other than
that look like you you start to develop
like you know what I have control over
my life if I make good decisions I would
go for it has nothing to do with my skin
color and I think we just both saw that
over time yeah I remember when we first
came across uh I didn't know the
difference between a liberal and a
conservative I came across Ben Shapiro
right I remember he was on Pierce Morgan
show that was going out guns yeah yeah
it was NRA Second Amendment yeah so I
was a batshit crazy a little bit of time
you know so I'm like looking at Ben
Shapiro and I was like oh man that white
supremacy he's got an answer for
everything you know and then I found out
that he was Jewish it's like wait a
minute
how can a white supremacist be Jewish
those two don't go together yeah so I
started listening then after I watched
Ben Shapiro even though I I hated
everything he said everything he said
made sense then I came across Larry
Elder start looking at Larry and then
and then he came across um Mark Levin
Mark Levin you on the radio yeah Keith
would just listen to him because he was
always talking [ __ ] about Obama we just
thought he was race
but the boy you listen to him it's like
dude's starting to make sense yeah you
know now who's introducing you to this
stuff is it your older brother or are
you just jumping across it YouTube I got
you and are you guys living together at
this time after the Marines uh no we're
not living together at the time but I
remember I started seeing Kevin said man
look at this new Ben Shapiro
he's killing this black guy over here
and uh it's just common sense really
yeah I think conservatism to see in
conservatism is all it is is common
sense yeah if you just sit and listen to
both sides and just be objective and
listen to what both sides are offering I
literally do not understand how anybody
could be a Democrat these days these I
mean you got you got women competing
against men you got they pushing all
this stuff on kids with the drag queens
and hysterectomies for girls yeah before
they go into people because they want to
be a man I mean this [ __ ] is this is a
freeing stuff it should not be being
pushed mainstream like it is I think the
breaking point for us is um I vote for
Obama's first term because I I thought
you know I didn't really know I just
voted from because he was black at least
be honest about it yeah I'm being honest
about it but um he was the eye opening
after Obama and I started listening to
both sides I hated Obama so much I
actually voted for Mitt Romney yeah they
take a net yeah whom Obama to flip to
Mid Romney yeah he was the only option
wow how did that happen yeah think about
that when Obama ran think about this it
was it was Mitt Romney and John McCain
and oh wait it was mokay and McCain in
12 years that's correct that was the
Republican option I think uh I think I
I'm not too much into conspiracy
theorists it's like they almost set
Obama up to be president yeah
they almost set him up to be president
as a one-term senator
what do you mean set them up yeah like
they planned it like they wanted a black
president yeah it's like they're both
liberal I mean like who's both liberal
uh McCain I mean they're Republicans but
they're liberal the way they vote the
way they uh their views it's liberal
like Mitt Romney is not a republican you
know what I mean McCain he's a
republican but no he's really not a uh
uh conservative it's like that was your
only option if you didn't want to say
Obama well don't these people are called
rhinos right Republicans and names only
wouldn't said the problem with you know
we can kind of talk Democrats
Republicans what what conservatives
these days but the the contingency where
you're talking about Liz Cheney or Adam
kinzinger are the people who are not you
know Republicans these are traditionally
what Republicans are now it's Maga right
so there's this kind of infighting
within that I don't even think that they
would say that Maga is not traditional
Republican so how do you process that I
just think there's a bunch of this
information Maga I mean Trump is not the
Republican Party correct you're Trump is
not the Republican party yeah correct
Republican party now are conservatives
uh people believe in conservatism the
Constitution that's what the Republican
party is it's not Maga it's not Trump
trump galvanized the constitutionalists
who are on the right but he is not the
Republican party that's just propaganda
that's all that's that's all that you
actually think that's bigger than that
to discredit the Republican Party sure
they are but do you actually think when
you Define conservatism the first thing
you go to is the Constitution because
that's not where I go whatsoever I don't
think I don't think 99 out of 100
Americans could tell you what the hell
the Constitution says left right or
something the same way I'm saying
freedom of speech freedom to carry a
weapon yeah you know yeah trading to a
family freedom to go to work I mean just
basic rights that we have under the
Constitution and over this last pandemic
they took all that away from us even the
Republicans initially shut everything
down but over time the Republicans was
the party say hey we're hiding from a
virus yeah this is stupid you can't hide
you can't run from a virus it's time to
go back to work and live our lives but
the only people that remained it shut
everything down and went to hide from it
was the Democrats yeah Republicans just
believe in Freedom let me live my life
yeah and Democrats think they know how
to uh
to uh live everybody's life for them I'm
not for that that's the Republican Party
mine also Republicans just want to be
left alone Democrats wants to be in
everybody's life it seems like to me you
know
yeah well no I you're absolutely right I
mean we're living in a state which is
called you know the free state of
Florida there's no doubt that Florida
DeSantis has led the way in terms of
Freedom you guys were living where
during the pandemic uh we listened on
Nevada you're in Nevada okay and how did
your state handle the pandemic Mass
shutdowns just stupidity okay because
we've been in Vegas a couple times right
Pat and and the first time we were there
I mean ever it was like desolate it was
uh yeah and it killed him because
everything in Vegas is tourism right so
it really bit them in the ass in the
Long Island we had to eventually open we
were the first ones that did an event
when they opened it up and it was a
surprise to everybody when they did open
it up but but let's keep going here
because again my interest is how you
guys went from Mom and Dad how you were
raised 14 years old you lose your dad
because you said a place he was working
at where you know he he goes on your
birthday which is we'll talk about a day
they're going to remember for the rest
of your life and then on the other side
Mom is saying hey racist be careful guys
all this other stuff then you go to the
military your older brother is kind of
like feeding you some stuff on the
conservative side then you hear some Ben
Shapiro Larry Elder you see some Mark
living and you're like hey this kind of
stuff makes sense as a conservative as
you're you know growing up so at what
point did you guys say we want to talk
about this when you when you created the
YouTube channel did you think you were
gonna go that route or was it more you
know let's review some supplements let's
test this out and let's do that and
let's go about just having fun okay talk
about current events and uh Fitness
relationships just having fun then over
time you know um we saw the direction
the country is going in I remember the
the breaking point for us was
um when the kid that was in Texas he
went to a Whataburger and he was wearing
his Maga hat yeah man we got attacked
yeah I took it from so he came up with a
great idea say let's let's don't say
what we are because we hadn't came out
of closet yet so close
yeah it was closely conservative so your
audience doesn't know yet damn no idea
how long have you been creating content
without them knowing about it uh we've
been on YouTube since four five six
years oh so you're going six years they
don't know your so the first time you
choose to do it is to wear Mega hats
yeah okay and how does that work out
yeah well we took you know what before
before I cut you up we used to take
because we always loved the cops we
would always people oh I love you you're
channeling with you relationship is
funny we would take pictures with cops
and I love cops because black cops we
don't even have a society this this
place is overrun by Thugs and and
criminals you know so every time we take
a picture with a cop just to show our
gratitude for police we would always
always get these crazy comments yeah
we'll post a picture on Instagram just
like man y'all taking pics with cops do
you know your history is it black people
talking [ __ ] oh two black people if you
want straight up all black people with
Tupac uh emojis if you I mean there's
ignorant people whether you're white or
black but if you want to see a real
ignorant person go check out a black
right they take ignorance to a whole new
Food level well how many times does a
black person called you an Uncle Tom I'm
sure you've lost count I'll be as rich
as him
well walk me through that process
because as a black person you guys are
both black guys correct me if I'm wrong
yeah I mean you kind of let that get
that good you know lights but wait a
minute I want to hear the story they
didn't tell the story let him finish
their story with the hat so what happens
there's a story coming up yeah let's do
a video Let's don't tell them that we
can serve but you can come down the
middle common sense right so we did the
video on Instagram posted it always said
in the video nobody should ever be
attacked for wearing
ahead First Amendment right right yeah
yeah so we I think we even said in the
video if you got Obama shirt nobody
should attack you if you got a trump
shirt nobody should attack you that's
your freedom that's the right you
haven't this is America this is America
right we treasure First Amendment right
in this country we put the video up
right and when we put it up you know how
you go into Instagram you can look at
your uh statistics yeah man it looked
like Bitcoin break down we lost like 50
000 15 000 followers in an hour yeah
what yeah yeah and you know that really
pissed me off
and I was like I got a bunch of liberal
I can't say the f word that's uh
derogatory
um I got a bunch of liberals and it just
really man it pissed me off so much
these people been watching me for years
and for them to just throw me away like
I'm a used condom
like that because of that video so it
really galvanized us I said you know
what let's start doing political content
I don't want these people following me
anymore
halfway through it like a week into it I
was like man this is a career suicide
when we do it
yeah but we never knew conservatives
were going to come out and support us
the way they did where's we're more
popular than we've ever been where were
you at the time when you when you lost
the 15 000 how many Subs we was around
475 000 followers on Instagram yeah and
now we are well over it felt like almost
I think it it almost got so bad we
almost fell under 400 000. yeah yeah
because of the post the concert at one
post okay
I never I didn't even say I was a trump
supporter I just said nobody should be
attacked that's all we said oh wait a
minute so you never put the Hat on you
never supported you just said nobody
should nobody should be attacked and
that cost you 15 000 same within an hour
within an hour [ __ ] fell out off the
table like Bitcoin holy [ __ ] and then uh
but like I said it like really pushed us
to start doing political content and um
and it's hard talking about politics
because it's so you get pissed off just
talking about it who who was the first
like if you were to say you know how
sometimes times like you know we do the
interview with Tate okay so hey man you
know we're gonna see what's gonna happen
and then all of a sudden the people that
send you a message like wait you follow
that I agree with everything the guy
says I just can't say publicly I agree
with and these are people in Hollywood
and sports are like just dming me
non-stop not stop and and many of these
interviews you do you'll see who likes
it like we'll do the mob interviews and
interesting communities like hey I watch
all the mob in it we'll do bodybuilding
the bodybuilding people show up who were
some of the first big names that message
you to say hey man we support you keep
at it we got your back where you said
we're not alone well a lot of people it
is in Hollywood they unfollow me
immediately yeah never heard from them
again yeah yeah well the black ones
anyway
but did you get did you when you said
you started getting support I mean this
was a name where you said wow this guy
supports us pro football players from
the Dallas Cowboys um pro baseball
players
um any political commentators any
political comment like did did you hear
from Larry Elder did you hear from
bongino did you hear from Candace did
you hear from any of these guys at the
time of course we know everybody knows
who you are I'm just saying at the time
they were they didn't reach out person
but they would retweet out that's a form
of support yeah so um
but uh it as far as the whole Uncle Tom
stuff that really stems from uh you know
black people think
um as a black person you have to vote
Democrats so they're not actually
thinking with their mind using their
brain when they vote they think with
their skin color so when they see me
vote for Republican they start to
project and think I'm voting for
Republicans because I love white people
I want to be white or I want to have
white friends or white girlfriends
that's this dumb [ __ ] I hear but it has
nothing to do with race while we're
Republican yeah black people have not
realized why I'm Republican has nothing
to do with my race yeah I understand why
you vote Democrats because you're black
and you think
um you think people Democrat Party on
your vote yeah Joe Biden thinks it too
he said if you don't vote for me you're
not black I mean I get that but that's
not why I'm Republican it has nothing to
do with race it has everything to do
with freedom and I'm living my life so
so so Keith Kevin yes by the way I'm
starting to realize the difference if I
assume yeah immediately no you got a
different smile than he's got it's all
in the eyes I this is how I tell you
guys Apart Nothing More not color the
eyes but the eyes of a different look
okay but but Keith question for you so
um you know for you what you say I don't
understand it's common sense to be a
conservative right I don't even know how
somebody could be a Democrat today so
okay there's a lot of people on the
other side that have fancy degrees that
are very well off that are financially
well off some of them are billionaires a
lot of them are billionaires you can't
tell me they're they're dummies to be
they're not dummies why do you think
they're Democrats what makes what do you
think why do you think they're Democrats
well first of all they're successful
because they're in the greatest country
in the world okay first and foremost
um the reason why they're Democrat is
they're not think in wrestling they're
not thinking logically they're not lose
using like at all I don't see how
anybody could support the Democratic
party with that policy how would they
become billionaires because then to
become become very successful in life
right you have to be able to reason
and to be able to stretch a dollar you
have to be able to hire the right people
you have to be able to put systems
together to raise Capital you know you
you you have to you have to do a lot of
those things to be able to succeed
regardless where you are politically
what why do you think these because
still Democrats use emotion to gain
votes just like what happened in Georgia
they're trying to change around the
voting yeah
um they want voter ID how did the
Democrats spend that they call it Jim
Crow this is racism they actually moved
to Major League Baseball game out of um
Atlanta Georgia to Colorado they used a
motion for boats once you can grab
somebody emotionally they stop thinking
tell a black person somebody's racist oh
that's all they need to hear that's it
you don't have to use logic to know
racism and bad so when they hear that
they believe it yeah I think a majority
of billionaires are are liberal because
they don't think for the uh little man I
mean if I'm a billionaire the first
thing I I don't see why any billionaire
would want to be a conservative to begin
with because to be a conservative man
you think about everybody as far as a
billionaire doesn't mean you just
because you're a billionaire you're a
rational or logical thinker all you
thinking about all you have for the most
part is great ideas
for a business you you put out a great
idea and everybody gravitates to towards
it and that's how you can you can earn
lots and lots of money then based on
ideas does that mean the so let's let's
let's identify it as that so at this
point you know I'm by the way I'm
playing the devil's Advocates I'm just
trying to enjoy a good debate here so
let's identify the fact that people who
are billionaires they're great at being
creative and coming up with the best
ideas does that also mean that the left
has given them better ideas to bind to
to vote for because they're attracted by
their ideas because look it's either
messaging it's either delivery of
messaging it's either that's exactly so
what's how you deliver your message okay
how you present your message Democrats
yeah are actually better politicians
than Republicans yeah
Republicans rely on the proof to push
out their message
Democrats play politics yeah they do a
lot of and hominin attacks they do a lot
of things that you know intellectuals
should not do in any civil debate they
say things they call people like racism
as a black man the first thing when I
heard somebody say somebody's racist I
didn't even double check it I
automatically assume that they're racist
because I was trauma because ever since
I was a young age so whenever I see a
Democrat say the other side is racist
they're being intellectually dishonest
because they already know for black
people
when he hit that word you're traumatized
do you think that's why so okay so now
we now we're getting to a point of
they're able to tap into the emotional
side Republicans are kind of like this
the truth how do you not understand it
this is logical you know right but you
know the whole thing about facts tell
stories sell you know Republicans are
trying to solve facts and people like
you're not emotional so you go going
back to the whole thing with the
emotional side okay so I'll tell you
like this Patrick uh Democrats they
um sale victimhood yeah nobody wants to
be able to like Republicans it's all
about pull yourself up by your
bootstraps you know as far as when it
comes to Democrats they like to sell
victimhood it's very hard to convince
somebody that you are the problem like
it's not your government it's not
Society it's not racism your life is
based on the ideas you come up with
in-house nobody likes that yeah nobody
wants to hear it and that's all very
hard sale that's a very hard sell very
good point yeah everybody wants to hear
oh it's not my fault it's the government
that's all my fault it's racism that's
why
um I mean as far as being a Democrat
they do have
you know they have it a lot easier when
they presenting their messages because a
lot of these things that they share with
people about racism uh transphobia all
these things a majority of them are just
made up terms to divide everybody so
they can grab your vote they could care
less about Society if you ask me a
Democrat like the one thing about uh uh
trans people they are high suicide rates
they die at a higher rate than other
people I heard Joe Biden say that uh
it's trans people are dying all the time
well he never says why they're dying why
are they die are they dying because
they're transgendered somebody's killing
transgenders or are they dying because
they're they uh they participate in
Risky activities
a risky Behavior or risky Behavior or
mental health issues well mental health
issues is leading that for sure yeah so
I mean I understand that's happening but
why is it happening why don't we address
why it's happening yeah instead if
saying uh explain why it's happening
they say it's as a result of transphobia
yeah white supremacy and then they call
us transphobic you know how many comedy
shows we got canceled because they label
us transforming when I'm not transphobic
at all yeah like nobody like they always
cut we had like three or four shows
Council like a lot of people don't know
my my my my youngest son his babysitter
was transgender nobody knows that yeah
she was a female she wanted to live a
life as a man she's transgender every
time she came there she's looking at
Entertainment Television looking at a
bunch of drag shows I didn't fire her I
didn't throw out of the house when she
came and sat me down said hey I'm going
to start transitioning
I was like we need transitioning uh you
got to give me two weeks notice
before I transition
across it yeah yeah I didn't fire I
still we still know her we still talk to
her from time to time I'm not
transphobic so so do you think do you
think this whole thing would emotional
logic okay so I'm gonna go to an
interesting place here uh uh uh with our
friend Adam so emotion and logic do you
think
maybe you know say the left is willing
to play dirty politics where maybe the
right doesn't get as dirty as they do
hypothetically a lot of people say this
absolutely but a politician do you think
this is why they lost their minds when
they found an equal match and a guy that
was willing to get dirty and play the
emotional game As Trump did yeah and
he's not part of the whole political
system because it like the bushes I mean
they've been in there like Trump is not
a politician yeah like when I look at
Obama you can listen to him he's a great
talker he's very charismatic it makes
you feel good inside yeah when I sit out
and listen to Trump if I'm if I'm a male
contented person I feel horrible about
that
right
he gives tough love he tells it like it
is he's not going to sugarcoat anything
yeah I mean he could take some lessons
from Ron DeSantis don't get me wrong
yeah but Trump is not a politician he's
like a UFC fighter yeah he's gonna like
when he he started going at it with Rand
Paul I mean that wasn't a debate that
was bullied you know what I'm saying why
all the conservatives gravitated towards
them because we just went through Mitt
Romney yeah and McCain yeah and Rand
Paul is a patriot I love Rand Paul yeah
he's an intelligent guy and he just
pushed about you again this this lesson
he's all over Fox yeah
so so you're saying so you're saying ham
he came in so for you do you see a
DeSantis now uh uh uh looking at what
worked in like I almost see like the
Santa's a very good student by the way
because the scientists you know in
sports uh the NBA changes every once in
a while so 30 years ago to win a
championship you needed a big man so it
was Akeem Robinson Shaq like everybody
needed a big man yeah big Ewing we got
to go get our big man right I was like
no you really don't you need a good two
guard or you needed this or you needed
that right and no no we're gonna do our
you know what he called the the Boston
when they had Ray Allen you need a big
three so LeBron Bosch and all this Cuts
I see DeSantis sitting there as a
student watching and saying let me tell
you Romney didn't work McCain didn't
work this guy made every one of them
feel so uncomfortable because he shot
fires first that's what I'm gonna do and
DeSantis in his own way is practicing
his trolling abilities because if you go
back to DeSantis four years ago he
wasn't a guy that was a troll I don't
know if you I don't remember descendants
being a troll but now you're seeing the
top gov now you're seeing all this stuff
that he's doing is he trying to say for
those of you that like that part of
trump don't worry I want to do that as
well and you get that as well on top of
the right policies I see a little better
than him but he still when he when he
says something you can't twist his words
you can very easily take Trump's words
and twist them around yeah like you
can't do that with Rhonda when Trump
said about you know the whole kneeling
thing was going on yeah and Chromecast
said father sons of [ __ ] throw them
out I'm like you're not gonna get the
black vote calling those black football
players moms Sons yeah I mean what do
you think I mean I like it I liked it
fight him get him on here she'll be
protesting a flag protest in just don't
protest our flag yeah but it's the right
to protest that's their right to protest
and I'm not saying they don't have the
right to do so but there's also such
thing as an effective protest that
protest was very ineffective you divided
to crunchy when you do that if you
really want to bring people together
hold up signs of white and black people
who's been killed and murdered by the
cops did you feel that was unjust yeah
hold up the flag because the flag that
flag stands for freedom for us all yeah
yeah so instead of coming up with black
lives matter should have been all lives
matter if you really but not it wasn't
about bringing things about police but
tell us about Divine this country they
really want to bring us together in
police brutality is a man that died just
like George Floyd's his name was last
name was Tipper it occurred in Texas
sex he died the exact same way those
cops are still on the force while they
cop that you know nailed on George Floyd
he's in prison because it's not about
bringing people together it's not about
police brutality that black lives matter
was all about keeping black people
thinking a certain way so they'll vote a
certain way yeah that's the only reason
why we have that organization in my
humble opinion yeah to push victim now
you look at that organization they're
suing each other over what money that's
why that whole organization's there yeah
money
yeah I mean I'm processing your guy's
story you know how basically your mother
uh raised during Jim Crow you guys were
devout liberals you voted for Obama now
08 you've been going through this sort
of red pill process you know basically
you're talking about BLM and you're
standing up against that I I think the
facts are by a percentage or two ninety
percent of black people vote for
Democrats I don't even think it's close
bro it's not like 55 not even close it's
only demographically does it yeah
exactly why do you what do you think
needs to happen for black people to
realize all right let me be a little bit
more open-minded and maybe even think
about voting Republican I'm not saying
they're going to pull it Switcheroo yeah
but to even yeah
like let it into their Temptations what
do you think will happen they always say
white supremacy is coming from the right
nah that shit's coming from the left if
they really want to change black
people's perspective when it comes to
politics versus liberalism and
conservatism Hollywood would get
involved but they're not going to do
that because black people that cash car
when it comes to politics
I believe in white supremacy but it's
not the white suprema of the man in the
Ku Klux Klan outfit saying in this in
that no white when I look at white
supremacs I look at the whole the
Democrats have on blacks and the way
they think and how they label other
blacks that are conservative that's how
I see whites but what do you actually
think needs to happen for that uh
transition well Hollywood ain't gonna do
nothing bro you know that what needs to
happen for what I'm curious for blacks
to actually consider to vote Republican
I'm trying to understand that mindset I
don't think because Hollywood's not
going to change that's the main reason
but media is not going to change that's
the main reason why it needs to start
with the Grassroots right you need to
start by black people like you guys in
Kansas civil rights leaders okay you
know you know but that's the thing man
in this day and age you don't need a
black leader what's wrong with a white
guy telling you the truth yeah why does
it have to be a black guy why can't it
be a Chinese kid if you if you really
want to judge people by the content why
does it have to be a black guy just
telling you the truth yeah I feel you on
on the surface but but people tell you
two colors very important it is
important especially the black people
because the main reason why uh Dr Martin
Luther King was assassinated the main
reason why Malcolm X was assassinated
because I don't you know the message
they put out there about being
independent work for yourself you know
work hard make good decisions that's the
main reason why those two memories and
guys don't forget color matters why did
you vote for Obama in 08 go ahead and
tell me oh there you go
but because you saw a black guy and you
said you know what I'll go with him yeah
forget about policies we lack
objectivity I gotta tell you the main
reason why I voted for Obama is because
what my mama went through I really
wanted her to see a black president and
before she died she's like man this
country has changed so much in the years
I've been here look at your brother he
retired from the army look how
successful he is he said my mom's told
me that she's a joke he look at you guys
on YouTube been having a good time said
man this country's changed so much yeah
there's no question about it I think
it's already happening Adam I think it's
already happening behind closed doors
look at look at the country as a human
being okay
as as the country is aging itself it's
also going to go back and forth with
different types of Crisis you experience
when you see certain things you're going
to change I think behind closed doors
people are still like the other day
cardi B she just went on around on
Twitter I know you guys had an issue
with cardi b a few years ago which was
very interesting hey if they would have
paid college tuition would have been
free I wouldn't need it to strip and
you're like what are you talking about
you guys came back I'm going to free
your taxes yeah exactly but she said
she's like you know my family's calling
me and I'm they're asking me to help
around financial help them out
financially which I'll do I'll do that
that's okay I'm doing it with some of my
family members but what is going on with
inflation and he says then she said the
line I don't know if you heard what she
said she said and I know some of you are
going to say well you're the problem you
voted for Joe Biden I'm not blind I know
what's going on I'm paying attention to
what's going on I have money so cardi B
wait what for her to even say that right
to even say that to get that audience
and then you know you're getting more
people gradually talking about this
where the other night we're having
spending time with a guy from Hollywood
who
we're going out there having dinner
we're having a nice conversation
together and he says listen man you guys
got to know there's a lot of
conservatives in Hollywood there's a lot
of conservatives of Hollywood one of the
best things that happened to Hollywood
and what's going on right now where I
think this is going to be flipping
I think
Netflix ruined Hollywood
I think Hulu Netflix I think Amazon I
think a bunch of these Otts I think
daily wire with the movies they're
making I think Barstool I think us I
think you know you go to some of the
smaller guys that are coming up I think
you know even uh Rumble with Chris what
he's doing over there I think every one
of these things is getting people to
check and we're like oh maybe before we
would have just dropped the guy like
this we can now because they have an
option to go to the other place maybe
before we could only put the video in
one place are we gonna take it down well
I'm gonna put it here you don't have
another place so Spotify now allows
certain users to put videos up so people
go watch it on Spotify people go to
rumble so I think what happened is when
you play this game of choking people and
silencing them
me and uh
tape we're talking about this the other
day is behind closed doors you're giving
birth to flag carriers who don't want to
be controlled they want to be left alone
and those flag carriers are also
passionate that they're willing to come
and find their types of people and
they're doing it today so I I think
Hollywood the days of a Weinstein having
a control of everybody you have to go
through him those days are gone Netflix
showed a formula that bunch of people
are following it's scared the crap out
of everybody in Hollywood they don't
know what to do right that's the best
thing same with social media by the way
right same with social media I think
it's going in the right direction and I
I think it's already going a Direction
with guys like people are less like
right now if you're listening to this
I'm looking at the commentary you know
our audience you know we have people
that are obviously capitalists but we
have some people think oh I hate Trump I
hate this I people listen and they said
this makes sense look at the story what
they went through you know sometimes
when you're going through something as a
kid you're like why the hell am I going
through this like what are you doing God
and then he's up there saying you'll
know in 30 years that's a long time
don't worry about it I'm gonna know how
to use you in 30 years be patient these
guys went through what they went through
God's use in them in a way right now
that by the way there's no book that's
going to convert in a different way than
their stories right now you're watching
two brothers telling their stories
here's what happens some people are like
yeah I kind of relate to this you know
this kind of does make sense on what's
taking place by the way you know from
just listen to you guys the feeling I
get is
in the most subtle way you guys are
leaning more towards the scientists than
a trump Administration in 2024 is that a
pretty good read or no uh I'll take them
both I don't know
okay but uh that's the funny thing about
it I don't know if Trump's gonna run and
I think I don't know just looking at
what the sense is doing I think he's
gonna run yeah and I don't may not run I
think I think Trump's going to run but I
think I I'm not necessarily think the
Santa is going to run with Trump though
yeah I think the Santa's gonna run yeah
and if Trump wants to run for president
that's going to get a well so there's a
whole different camp that even you know
Tucker kind of is you know alluded to a
little bit that you know this indict
indicting thing do you think any of
that's going to be taking place you
think there's going to be like that okay
got it but I mean they've been being
indicted yeah I mean for years they've
been saying he's been doing this and
that and nothing ever came of it and now
they're raped in this house I still
don't believe until I see it yeah what
do you think Keith where are you at with
that could it happen could it get that
ugly where they may do that to him to
just eliminate the competitor they
impeached him twice for just breathing
so I wouldn't I wouldn't put it past I
mean what are they going to indict him
for being orange I mean I mean he is
guilty of that bro
I mean I mean you might not like you
know what I had to get over when I was
when I when I made that switch over to
conservatism I always voted for people
who I liked and I and that it brought
that to my head when you said that you
don't vote for people who you like you
vote for people who's going to make you
know that's gonna make this a better
place to live you vote for their
policies has nothing to do if he's
handsome
if you like them if he's charismatic has
nothing to do with it I want an [ __ ]
in offense if he's going to take care of
my family my rights and protect our
country you don't care if he's an
[ __ ] if he takes a story yeah but see
your objective most people ain't
objective yeah
you know yeah well I'll tell you what uh
bill you guys uh watch Bill Maher ever
yeah yeah okay he's getting more and
more leaning more and more he's just a
typical Democrat he's not far left he's
just that's what he's Democratic
traditional liberal yeah but you talked
about being an [ __ ] right and I think
that's part of the reason that Biden you
know is the president now because people
were sick of the [ __ ] Tendencies but
I'm going to read you what Bill Maher
had to say it was basically saying that
there's the rise of the meh voter the
meh like ah just
I just don't ah Trump you know this
whole concept and he said one of the
reasons obviously you know you as you
know kind of comedian type guys you'll
appreciate this he said they're
basically saying there are so many good
reasons that for to give Democrats your
vote again this is on Bill Martin he
basically says well things could be
worse inflation right the economy right
there's no other option because the
other guy's a [ __ ] dick that's what
he says about this and that's how people
basically process Trump because I
totally understand that if maybe if
it'll benefit the country this is a good
question if it benefits the country
would rather have an [ __ ] in office
or a nice guy and the country kind of
goes down the hill you know that's the
kind of the the what the country
essentially grappling with right now
well you're saying you'd rather have the
[ __ ] yeah I think for the most part
if Trump in office I'm just speculating
I think if he's in office I don't think
Putin invades Ukraine I think it's a
huge possibility you know yeah that's
what's leading to a majority of the
inflation we do hear that argument they
they address it I do hear that argument
all the time and you very well might be
accurate the other side the flip side
people are saying all right cool all
right I don't think Trump if he was in
office they would invaded Ukraine the
other side is basically saying cool
maybe you're right but now that the war
is being fought whose side would Trump
be on would he be sign up be pandering
to Putin at this point would it be
basically sending a lot of money Ukraine
these are the questions that the left is
basically responding with right I'm not
saying that's right or wrong this is the
best thing if he was in office he would
probably be siding with Putin nothing I
don't think he'd be signed with anybody
I think more than anything he would be
trying to side with Ukraine because he
wanted his son in uh son to be
investigated I think it would be more
Ukraine side the thing that would would
have prevented that whole war in
ukrainian's diplomacy yeah Putin's been
saying it for years decades
um Ukraine is not to join
um NATO yeah that's all they wanted they
got two that's important yeah well
Ukraine too much United States
ukrainians are like Russian blood you
know that's what happened in Ukraine is
like California breaking away from the
United States and becoming wants to join
let's say uh China China Russia that's
that's equivalent what Ukraine is trying
to do the United States would invade
California
right being that best interest if
California wants to be a part of Russia
what is the USA going to do
they're going to invade California
because they don't want Russia sitting
right there with all their Arsenal they
don't want communism on that doorstep
like that no no
I don't be I don't I don't think what's
going on in Ukraine is good by any
stress what do you mean by that who
doesn't want who who doesn't want
communism on their doorstep the United
States
California turns to a communist country
uh they go with uh Soviet Union USA is
going to invade California that's why
I'm not saddle with any side by the way
but I'm just giving you the reasons why
Russia did what they did yeah that's why
they did if diplomacy would have came in
yeah a leader if somebody leader yeah
like maybe Trump maybe I don't know
maybe I'm just wrong but somebody
sitting down talking to both sides they
don't like this we can't do this but we
can do this
if we did if they just had three men I
mean it shouldn't even come to the uh
there's people dying in Ukraine right
yeah it shouldn't even come to war
anymore because nowadays these wars
nobody wins none of these wars yeah I
mean like when you go to war nowadays
like it's not like back World War Two
World War One people actually won those
Wars these wars they would have not
nobody wins nobody wins so when Russia
invaded Ukraine it could have been so
many things done to prevent from this
ever happening well I mean the the
greatest analogy these days it's it's
essentially a proxy war the the entire
world is Galvanized I mean I say the
entire world the entire Western World
United States the EU other countries are
basically using Ukraine as a proxy war
because nobody wants to see Russia
succeed ironically it's a Russian
economy I think GDP was actually
positive during during this war because
they've escalating gas prices the whole
situation is weird Okay you're funding
Ukraine for the war but you were buying
gas or oil from Russia I mean it doesn't
make any sense yeah why can't we just be
financially independent I don't
understand why we gotta get involved
with all these skirmishes across to and
it's just it's just speaking skirmishes
you saw what uh Biden had to say about
obviously Ukraine and continuing to fund
Ukraine but you saw what he said about
Taiwan and China
how did you process that Pat which part
of it where basically said if it's this
interview yeah
if China invades Taiwan would you send
American troops to Taiwan he said yes
and I think the the interview had asked
it again he said yes he would defend
Taiwan but did you also hear what he
said when he was that he said yes many
times and then he says what would you do
to Russia he says if I if I know I
wouldn't tell you I wouldn't tell you
what I'm going to be doing by the way I
respect that yeah I like that answer
okay there's a part where he says is the
worst of the economy ahead of us no it's
behind us you can't say that yeah I
agree but what would you expect him to
say yeah the worst times but what you're
supposed to say is be straight up like
what you're supposed to do we don't know
we're going to find out if we make some
of the right choices we're going to find
out what's going to be taking place
rather than saying a flat uh no but but
I do want to say something here about
what's going on during uh uh with what
you guys are talking about you're saying
Trump would you know would you support
this would he support that a couple
things happened just recently with
Armenia Tyler if he can pull up that one
uh uh tweet so so here's here's here's
very important for us to don't put it on
the screen yet until I kind of explain
what happened so in the last week
Azerbaijan troops attack Armenia Armenia
has a prime minister pashino so attack
Armenia Kappa Hunter soldiers die
there's a lady named anush which you see
the story circulating all over the place
who the azerbaijani military apparently
took her they you know raped her they
got they took a rise out they put rocks
there they took out her fingers put on
her mouth and this story is going all
over the place and another Soldier
Armenian Soldier this has been happening
constantly now when somebody says
stories like this you know what a lot of
friends from Azerbaijan will say how
could you say that you're selling us
that evil people and no problem fine
let's speculate together as a person
who's Armenian who you know which side
I'm going to lean on and I quite frankly
don't even think that pashinian is the
right leader in the country right now
because while you're doing this
everything's about alliances you create
look at Israel Israel created alliances
with America you went and were bought
out by China and then Russia is
supporting you in a way but they kind of
run Armenia you're not really the
president of our the Prime Minister of
Armenia it's really Russia but Russia's
also playing politics for a couple
different reasons so Watch What Happens
turkey yeah this is the part where a
person like Putin has a good argue not
necessarily Putin some people who are
from the side that they're saying NATO
is playing games this is what a Turkish
Member of Parliament just said a couple
days ago I want you to play it and then
I'm going to read what it translates to
he just said this on September 15th okay
play it put the audio up and then I'll
say exactly what he's saying to you go
and press play
so here's a message I don't know if you
get in the audio or not start over Tyler
okay if you're getting it don't worry
about it you can go watch us on Twitter
here's what he says we say to the
Armenian Administration make up your
mind I remind you once again that the
Turkish nation has the power to erase
Armenia from history geography and that
they stand at the limit of our patients
this is a member of parliament from
Turkey
turkey is part of NATO
if a message like this is being given
this is like somebody from Germany
saying hey uh Israel if you guys make a
comment don't let us remind you of what
we did to you guys back in the days with
this and guess what this guy can you go
up to his Twitter account please go
straight to his Twitter account you have
his handle he's active on Twitter that's
him so he just said this three days ago
this guy's still active on Twitter FYI I
am not imposing for a guy like this to
be banned I want people like this on
Twitter do you know why because people
can get to see that these types of
people exist and you can make a decision
for yourself so now I want to give a
shout out to somebody
Nancy Pelosi I rarely will give a shout
out to Nancy Pelosi but today's one of
them Nancy Pelosi to me is 10 times more
presidential than Joe Biden or Kamala
Harris's now forget about politics
forget how you feel about any of these
three characters here let me just tell
you what I mean by this Nancy Pelosi
went to Taiwan and China said if you do
shove look what we're going to do to you
she still went Nancy Pelosi in the
middle of all this
challenges faced between Armenia and
Azerbaijan she goes to Armenia and
spends a day there with a couple of the
political leaders that went with her
Armenian folks that went with her and
she goes pays a respect for what's going
on now here's the part
yesterday I go on Fox News YouTube
channel I go on MSNBC YouTube channel I
go and see it in a YouTube channel I
type in CNN Armenia you know what you
see this much
I go type Fox Armenia this much Pelosi
goes to Armenia nothing's talked about
right so turkey is got azerbaijan's back
okay turkey is a part of NATO and they
made this threat and what does erdogan
say going around saying we're going to
do whatever we're going to do to Armenia
we can make you guys erase and this you
know Parliament member can say what he
can say and they stay on so moral the
story is the final one you got a bite
now Kamala Harris was just asked as the
Border safe did you see a response yeah
where they ask the question so is the
Border safe and I don't know if you got
the video if you can pull it out because
the video was just absolutely ludicrous
on what she's saying like you can't even
sit there and process it and say did she
really just say that Tyler I don't know
if you got it up or not you look like
you're going through all of them yeah
okay watch this answer here very weird
the border is secure but we also no go
back because if you didn't go back in
particular over the last four years back
refresh because it needs to be fixed he
asked a question
okay just question first and then it
goes
okay secure but we also have a broken
immigration system in particular over
the last four years before we came in
and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people across this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this Border's security listen
to our answer
we have
a secure border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
and our Administration oh you know when
I hear give that answer all she's
thinking about is how is this going to
be written about in the paper how is
this going to be cut so what can I do to
give the right answer or I'm not going
to be judged for it FYI
listen people say Nancy plays politics
Everybody Plays politics guess what you
play politics I want the person playing
politics to go to Armenia I want the
person playing politics to go to Taiwan
I want this person playing politics to
go to the border so you don't want to go
to the Border guess what they brought
the border to you did you see all these
people coming off the bus in front of
our house what'd you think about that
when you saw that would come out I mean
if you stand by those policies if you're
a sanctuary City why wouldn't you
welcome these people in and provide for
them but I think in Martha's Vineyard
they actually deported them with the
National Guard like how can you say you
pro-sanctuary city but if you do as soon
as we see some people because I know
these border cities in Texas I think
they're overwhelmed so if you're if
you're a sanctuary City and you stand by
those policies why wouldn't you welcome
these people in your communities your
neighborhoods and help them dislike the
red states are doing or like Florida's
doing I mean one state can't take but so
many uh immigrants into the country
before they you know become overwhelmed
did you hear one day said
Martha's Vineyard isn't prepared like
the southern border of Texas is for
these number of migrants and they're
like what are you talking about it's
like 50. you got 50. they got 2 million
Obama's got plenty of room yeah and then
once you open your place to let them
live you know stay a little bit like
yeah I don't know about that we're not
going to respond to that one you know
excellent too right but
so question for you I I don't think what
the Santa's dude did is all good or all
bad meaning they're like with everything
we're discussing by the way whether it's
Pelosi and I gotta give respect to Pat
right now yeah we're so easily
abilifying she is way more presidential
than come on by but they they don't add
things like this on TV on Fox or CNN
because you can't politicize it you
can't use it to earn votes it's not it's
a non-story today
Armenia yes oh The Armenian story no I
mean I'm talking about Martha's Vineyard
you know on one side it's you know good
for DeSantis you know he needs to stand
up and draw attention to what the hell's
going on at the border and you know he's
kind of you know trolling uh the Gavin
newsoms of the world the combos of the
world and the Obama's of the world and
the other other side you kind of have
the left saying listen he's just playing
politics here basically he's he's um
using immigrants as political pawns
essentially and then if you're in
Florida these are Venezuela a lot of
people what they sent I think were there
50 people Tyler they were all Venezuelan
as well no I I can't tell you how many I
mean I'm born and raised in Miami how
many Cubans and Venezuelans are just
they've come here basically looking for
a better look what's your point what's
my point is this is that dentist is
right and wrong what I'm saying is that
yeah that that it
it's not all right or all right why is
it wrong tell me why it's wrong okay
well if you're in Florida yeah okay and
I assume that you know that DeSantis is
running again for the governor of
Florida my question is is could this
backfire I happen to think that he's
gonna beat Charlie Chris handily right
that's just running again if you don't
beat that okay correct yeah however
okay if you're a Hispanic yeah and you
see you know and maybe you're undecided
because again Florida's a purple State
it's not like it's you know 70 30 it's
kind of closer to 55 45. is this
something that a Hispanic will look at
and say yeah this doesn't sit well with
me again we're in South Florida we're in
Florida could this backfire no because
the guy's running for
this guy's running for president you
know but he needs to win Governor I
totally get that and did Chris you
think Charlie Chris is like it's like
you're thinking like a anyways okay
everybody's I'm already one step ahead
of you I'm with you 100 I think
Cassandra's is going to be Chris so did
he need this but here's the part but
this potentially let me explain to you
what this does to America okay for two
years how long has Kamala and Biden been
the president and the VP how long has it
been two years two years for how long
have the people been asking for her to
go to the border and she's the Border
Cesar how how long Czar how long has she
gone to uh how long have they been
asking for this two years has she gone
yet no well guess what if you don't go
to the problem don't worry I'm gonna
bring it to you and America says thank
God for ballsy leader like that to put
them in the corner and say what are you
gonna do about it now yeah what are you
gonna do about it now let's see how
you're going to react to it now now they
were not expecting this they have lost
their minds DC Martha's Vineyards
they've lost their minds Chicago they
don't even know how to handle the
situation like
exactly that was the whole point why
DeSantis that's why the governor in
Texas did what they did
y'all about uh immigration until it's on
your doorstep they just want to show the
hypocrisy of the democratic party and
that's a lot of democrat voters don't
see that hypocrisy and that's all all in
there for everybody to see but I do
think a lot of people are starting to
see it though remember not you don't
need 50 to flip yeah I do think there is
a five percent yeah you need three
percent I do think there's people that
are sitting there saying well babe did
you see that kind of does make sense
look at the way they're reacting you're
calling the why they're calling the
reserve they're calling for 50 people
and these guys are dealing with two
million look at the pictures they're not
even saying anything even on 60 Minutes
even everybody on the left these are on
the left they're asking them the
questions about the border and Kamala
can't even answer the question I don't
know I think we got a problem here yeah
Trump's a race is xenophobic now look
what they're doing exactly xenophobic
races it's just opening up people's eyes
that's why they Republicans are being
better politicians now as in Texas and
Florida in the Bill of politician you
got to be two steps in front of your
opponent yeah so and FYI for for you
Adam you you got to know that you know
Florida doesn't have illegal immigration
as much as Texas and California and
Arizona does correct very you've you
wanted the people that come here
immigrants are dying to be here like
Cuban refugees and raps I'm not saying
folks on the other side or not they're
also going through a lot of sacrifices
I've said this many times if I was
somebody that's living down then I'm
seeing what the the mafia is doing and
I'm living in Mexico in some of these
cities I'm also going to figure out a
way to come up and bring my kids here
even if it costs my lives I'm doing that
but that's not the point the point here
is that it is a different situation I
love the fact that he's bringing a
problem to them and hey how you want to
react to it people have to let me pose a
different question yeah okay
do you think like you're an immigrant
okay you you were not born in America
right you guys were born in America okay
my family Russian immigrants that fled
basically the Bolshevik Revolution in
you know 1917 whatever but do you think
immigrant like I feel I I wholeheartedly
believe that immigrants should be
propped up and appreciated more than
they are I don't know I'm saying right
you came through the front door your
family came through the front door he
came through the front door correct
these people not coming through the
front door correct and that's my point
but I guess my question is do you think
that we're villainizing these immigrants
when they should they're looking for
because uh when you come into a country
legally you're automatically a criminal
like we had some shows comedy shows in
London our Visa wasn't right they're
Restless theaters in the immigration in
London we was in Immigration jail in
London yeah four sold out shows yeah
I've had this divided we couldn't even
talk to each other had us in cages yeah
literally in London how long ago was
this this was a couple years before the
uh pandemic hit got it yeah so they all
border [ __ ] you should not have an open
border and the way they let these people
in I'm all about people coming here yeah
if they're fleeing crime um you know
things of that nature and they come in
and say hey I'm I'm running
um being persecuted in my own country
and you come through our back door what
are you doing I'm all for that but the
majorities people are just coming here
because they just want a better life and
and I'm under under the understanding
that you don't fit the parameters or the
prerequisites of even coming into our
country to sick Asylum you don't think
that's
but by the way I want to read you what
Hillary Clinton said about this whole
situation Hillary Clinton says Martha's
Vineyard situation is literally human
trafficking no one wants open borders uh
on Friday Hillary Clinton agreed with an
MSNBC Morning Joe host assessment that
the sending of 50 migrants to Martha's
Vineyards was human trafficking she
added that nobody wants open borders who
has any idea of how government and
countries work but nobody wants inhumane
terrible treatment of human beings
either what we should be what we should
have been doing is to come together to
reform change and better fund the system
uh by which we deal with these issues
but some people like Governor Abbott of
Texas would rather have an issue than be
a part of the solution I'm sorry Hillary
Clinton how about holding Kamala
accountable to going to the Border they
were doing the same thing before that
the Republican Governors start doing
that they were doing the same thing you
made a great point you think we
villainizing immigrants and we're using
them as political pawns that's a great
point but the Democrats have been using
them as a political Pawn the entirety
that's how we got here that's how we got
here yeah
stand where you come from they they're
already political pawns because most of
these people should have been turned
turned away before they even get here
you can't even come through uh from from
what I I might be wrong on this but if
you're seek an asylum in a country you
have to first apply to the country you
enter and then you progressively get to
the United States a lot of these people
are breaking all kinds of international
laws we lived in Germany at a refugee
camp for a year and a half before we
came to the states literally at a
refugee camp in Germany for a year and a
half and then we finally the day we got
our green card to come here man we were
doing backflips yeah when we knew we
were going to be coming it was like the
happiest day of my life November 28 1990
is when we came here but I will never
forget that day you made it uh never I'm
telling you guys how about you how about
you me what his family came here he was
born here oh he was born yeah oh you're
lucky you I know yeah I know yeah yeah
I'm very lucky just real quick I think
he made a good point that it's all about
the message right that's what you said
everything is about the message right
it's not very often I do this but I have
to agree with Adam and that two wrongs
don't make it right I understand 100
what DeSantis did I get why he did it
the backlash he did he's proven their
Hypocrites everything but now look at
how this is being flipped on him right
now he's the human trafficker nobody
gives a [ __ ] that they've been flying
illegal immigrants to 49 states across
the country to flip them nobody cares
who does he have to win if he wants to
run for president the Suburban women
right what do the Suburban women look at
and say when they see this Rhonda Santos
is a horrible person this is a very
trumpian move of him and he has to be
careful because he's playing with fire
yeah
those uh those uh women they love
Newsome right well no you're absolutely
right Gavin Newsom could be president in
2024 because nobody pays attention to
policies anymore right it's a popularity
but I think uh for most of us clearly
look at AOC yeah I mean yeah I think for
the most part when they say human
trafficking it's not human trafficking
that's that's hyperbole you know it's
all hyperbole yeah nobody nobody's gonna
look that far into it nobody's going to
take it yeah so most people don't you're
right and listen I get what he did and I
think it's great the idea of it is great
right I agree with it but he has to be
very careful because he's playing with
fire and he's giving them the message
what's the alternative though let me let
me ask you a question what do leaders do
you guys want a bunch of pansies that
are marketers yeah but this does it what
does this do this doesn't it let me tell
you if I'm on the southern border I'm
sitting there saying thank God he did it
and he ain't even in my state no I want
a leader bro I don't know what world you
guys are living and I'm not trying to
get a if you want to get a CMO as a
president you're not looking for the
right guy the Santa saying the CMO you
can get a you know a lot of different
people to be that job you want a leader
to be the president
half the reason why the mess is taking
place right now with Ukraine potentially
Taiwan that could potentially happen
soon is because ain't nobody afraid of
America today so I don't I don't mind
that he's flexing his muscles by the way
FYI you have to understand this other
part there is risks to you choosing to
be a leader there is risks there's risks
to you showing that you're a true leader
there is a very risk to you being a
tough father there is risks to you being
a high expectation type of a debt
there's risks to you being a guy that
expects a lot from people there's my
kids are going onto baseball my son is
going to baseball practice right now and
this place is going I'm standing on the
sidelines just watching to see how these
guys coach the kids and I see hey you
don't come out hey you don't do this run
two laps hey boom five push-ups hey you
dropped the ball to five push-ups hey
you didn't do this go run over here at
the end of the two hour practice these
guys are sweating you know what I said
on the sidelines he's in the right place
these are real coaches coaching these
guys they're tough now listen at the end
of the day I don't care about Optics I
want a leader today America is
desperately looking for a leader now
don't get me wrong I'm not telling the
centers to go on a podcast on smoke weed
to win some people that are going to
vote for him I'm not telling you he's
not going to be doing that but the fact
that this guy's got the audacity to go
out there and do things like that he's
showing I can help solve a lot not only
Florida's problems because people track
record-wise give me one Governor's
resume FYI did you just see what just
happened let me just give you guys a
stat here does anybody know who just
broke the record for the most money ever
raised by by governor in the history of
America it's a guy named DeSantis so he
just broke the record for the most money
ever raised by a governor in the history
of America his name is Ron DeSantis how
does that happen people from other
states are supporting this guy they
ain't even in here people from other
states so if a guy is going to take a
risk like that I'm for you taking risks
because quite frankly too many people on
all the other sides are playing are way
too safe I want a real leader today I
want a real leader that's going to go
out there so let's let's continue this
conversation with a Newsome call out on
what Newsome just said so Newsome just
came out and said the following which is
on page four
uh Newsome okay California governor
Gavin news some challenges Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis to debate this is
a CBS story on Friday Newsom tweeted if
you want to put it up and zoom in a
little bit Tyler so we can see this
hey uh Ron DeSantis clearly you're
struggling distracted and busy playing
politics with people's lives since you
haven't uh only overriding need
attention let's take this up and debate
I'll bring my hair gel and you bring
your hairspray name the time before
election day and he tags CNN right so he
puts this tweet and then on Thursday uh
Newsome called for an investigation into
Republican Governor sending busloads of
migrants of Democratic states to protest
the bite Administration immigration
policies in a Tweed Newsom specifically
called that the santis and Texas
governor Abbott over their cruel policy
of busting migrants out of their states
to cities with Democratic Mayors as part
of a political strategy do you have uh
the sentences response did you find that
one or no so when you saw this what was
your first reaction when you saw Newsome
sadness Adam
oh I think this is A Tale of Two Cities
basically best of times worse at times I
mean this has been kind of coming this
way for a while where basically you have
I mean you have the free state of
Florida and the lockdown State of
California and you have the two two
figure heads whether you like them or
not these are basically you know the
uh Gen X version of the current
presidency right now right Biden and and
Trump in their 70s about to be 80. here
are two guys in their what DeSantis is
what 44 at the oldest how old is Newsom
in his late 40s yeah I think this is on
the upswing and I think basically we've
seen a lot of uh recruiting I think
didn't uh DeSantis put up a massive uh
outdoor billboard basically calling out
to Santa's we have two Governors calling
each other out right and uh
it remains to be seen I'd love to see
this debate I'd love to see this debate
I think the whole world would want to
say this debate this is a presidential
debate if you ask yeah but go ahead
Newsome is an opportunist he and that
means it's like Pharaoh O'Rourke I just
like like when Beto when the gun
violence down in Texas he took advantage
that because he's running for governor
yeah he has uh presidential dreams and
he's he's an opportunist and I mean that
in the most negative connotation ever he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about any of this
stuff he just wants to become president
so keep talking I'm choking this is the
beauty of having a twin brother looks
just like you have exact same opinions
you could be choking your brother picks
up the ball and goes with it and he's
spending a lot of money that was donated
to him right for these these Billboards
because he doesn't have to worry about
spending money in California because
that's just you know majority that you
know even though that whole state is red
for the most part it's San Francisco LA
make that whole state blue he doesn't
have to worry about you know losing
seats to demo I mean to Republicans
because that state is just just blew
from those two major cities why do you
think the scientist keeps getting
elected even during the recall I mean he
was the mayor of San Francisco San
Francisco that place has turned into an
absolute [ __ ] right okay then he
becomes uh governor of California we've
seen what's going on I think you know
they they have the the first year ever
Pat correct me if I'm wrong they had a
net loss in Immigration people that
moving the [ __ ] out of California yeah
he has to recall he beats Larry houndour
easily I don't understand how do they
keep vote for this how these election
results come in it's just weird
it's like how do Democrats have that
much power in one state well I mean it's
the most liberal state in the country
I'm not shocked I'm not convinced that
it is though because when we do comedy
shows out there people turn out there as
if I'm in Florida really yes how recent
um I mean we have like where's up in um
can I forget that City Bakersfield and
the other well the Bakersfield Bakers
these are these are conservative cities
California like whenever we go anywhere
in California it sells out I mean fast
yeah
yeah well what's the population I think
there's 40 million people in California
I mean there's going to be if one third
of California is Republican so you still
got 15 million people there here's my
thoughts on the Newsome uh yeah go for
it DeSantis uh uh debate okay so for me
I could care less about being a CNN
format Newsome here's my suggestion to
you choose a podcast format go for three
hours okay and do it this way you come
to us okay there you go we will
guarantee three hours we'll guarantee
minimum a million dollars to both just
to participate to your campaign we'll do
a super chat people will be able to call
in all that other stuff but it shouldn't
be two minutes I'll stop now okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay no no no no no
no no no I want to see if the Santa I
want to see if Newsom can talk for 10
minutes with an answer and I want to see
if the Santa's gonna give a long answer
so right what do you think about the
issues that we're facing and and let let
it be a different kind of a format
you'll get the money's worth I wouldn't
go to CNN I wouldn't go to Fox I would
go to a podcast pick and choose a
three-hour podcast a lot of people do it
just the other last week we broke the
record for the longest podcast to go you
know whatever it was for the week we got
five five and a half million views on
yeah we crossed five million five hour
podcast got
200 million minutes watched on this one
podcast that we got last week that went
out on Tuesday or Monday I don't know
what it was there correct right after
I'd love to if it's not us choose
somebody else okay pick somebody else
and but have the sit down because if you
guys are gonna do the traditional way I
have zero interest in watching it yeah I
would love to see a bigger move in
campaigns going like I'd love to see
those guys sitting down with a Rogan
okay sitting down over here sitting down
in a place where it's three hours a good
moderator ask challenge each other and
let's see what it's going to look yeah
any other format is just disingenuous
it's not enough time you're not giving
it's totally fake how can you have
somebody you having a open conversation
with somebody but they're on your side
and they're just throwing you softball
questions though yeah you know it's just
it just because I don't trust anything
you know for the most part on TV because
you have to double check everything you
heard yeah and by the way the cool thing
about this kind of a format is do if you
if you tell a lie the audience in the
chat box chat but they're gonna go off
the live chat right right so versus when
they're doing it there there's not you
know everybody has to but everyone's
like oh my god did you know what they
said it's a very different format that a
lot of these guys fear they're not
comfortable doing that they would much
rather be in a controlled environment
where they get to control the end the
question they come on the podcast it's
like a brawl yeah but that's what
America does that's what America
deserves exactly why do you think
podcasts are blowing up yeah why do you
think there's such a yearning for just
free talk when we when we're
contemplating putting the the Tate out
the interview out we're like do we want
to do it in like three segments that
goes [ __ ] it Go the whole five hours
we're like okay yeah and we didn't know
we didn't know what would happen but
that's what there's a yearning for just
open dialogue and open that without
being filtered and up two minutes sorry
you gotta stop talking now but that's
that's what Newsome would never come on
this or any other podcast you can see
the comments you you can see the you can
see everybody's uh commentary like when
you go to YouTube and look at a biting
video when he first got elected he even
though he got over 80 million votes all
the dislikes everything was more
dislikes than likes even on CNN or
msnbc's YouTube channel what did YouTube
do they did away with that dislike
button yeah what are they hiding he's
got over 80 million votes these people
gonna if he's got 80 million voters this
should come out and stand up for this
guy that's why he'll never come on here
because it's gonna be in the comments I
have an idea everybody's gonna see it
what do you think about a hundred
thousand dollar gift card to French
Laundry
lifetime supply eat there for the rest
of your life I'll cover the bill every
time you go and just say this is on
Patrick with David this is some Patrick
with David I have a theory on why uh LA
or California keeps voting for the uh
the Gavin Newsom uh and this and I
realized this this was a month or so ago
this was right around July 4th
um where I watched again back to the
Newsome the santis debate situation
going on DeSantis did his whole what was
it topgov where it was basically right
when uh the movie Top Gun came back out
it kind of yeah you know he kind of did
his whole thing and you know I gave it a
c plus it wasn't exactly like
it didn't wow me but I get it he was he
was doing his thing okay
um I kind of thought he used the Top Gun
on his kid I mean he wasn't he was a he
was a lawyer in the the Marines or in
the Navy right he wasn't actually in the
Navy
or he wasn't a marine all right I had to
give him a c plus and then I saw what
Gavin Newsom had to say on July 4th and
it was the most scripted plastic
Hollywood manufactured non-charismatic
thing I've ever seen and I'm not a
Californian I don't I don't follow
Newsome like that yeah pack follows it a
lot closer because he much like you
lived in California for 20 years 15
years it was full of lies and I was just
like
and I just gave DeSantis a c plus okay
great whatever this one commercial and
then I saw Newsome's Fake Plastic
[ __ ] hi here in California I'm like
right get this freaking Ken doll out of
my face yeah it comes off like he's
reading it but that's what I realized is
that California is the land of plastic
Hollywood fakeness and they're like yeah
that's exactly what we've embraced for
decades now and that's maybe why it just
ugh it just it gives me the American
Psycho Vibes yeah when you listen to a
Democrat they they sound a lot like
Obama it you know the mannerisms he do
the smile the hand gestures and it's
just you've seen it so many times even
with Bill Clinton he had that same
dominatoon and when you look at DeSantis
or Trump you can tell it's not scripted
it's just coming from you know right
here in the heart the way they look the
way they look uh that that hand gestures
it's just everything just comes out so
more genuine than when you see yeah but
yeah brother uh Newsome is no Obama or
Clinton okay there are a hundred times
realer than that dude and I'm not saying
that they weren't you know playing
politics but yeah
Newsome is in a fake category of his own
like I've never seen bring the hair gel
let's go yeah yeah pbd yes sir let's go
into that Kim Kardashian story which if
you can't pull up Instagram let's go
yeah I just thought about that the other
day did you did you see your Instagram
post that's a picture right there she
posted and she said I'm excited to be
part of Hillary and Chelsea Clinton
since Incredible Journey to find out
what it truly means to be gutsy what uh
stream the docu-series now on Apple TV
you didn't see this I didn't say this
okay so watch this go into the
commentary see what her audience is 330
million followers look what they're
saying about it uh bad no uh yikes
shaking my head nauseous no what lol
sick that's a bummer laughing my ass off
bye no pizza gag nope sus oh this ain't
it God what are you doing this is
embarrassed but by the way this is
what's crazy about it a hundred percent
of the comments I just read yeah guys
this is this is and it's not like Kim
Kardashian is a Republican or a Democrat
right Kim is right in the middle
her followers should be supporting
Forbes International 2021 Woman of the
Year okay but they're not so click a
little bit more maybe maybe this is just
I don't know maybe go a little lower and
let's continue so keep going
look what I said this was two I forgot I
commented here it looks like Hillary's
2024 campaign for presidency starting
early she's in campaign mode yep by the
way stay there I fully think she is
because you know what Bill Clinton just
did the last time he did his uh you know
how he does this event every year you
know the Bill Clinton event he does
every year Global yeah initiative thing
you know when's the last time he did it
do you know what's the last time they
put the event together 2016 2016 and
they just brought it back up in 2022.
this woman smells opportunity for being
a president and she's using her not in a
negative way this is being plain
politics she's bringing Chelsea along to
not only get her more eyeballs because
she's one they're gonna run but to also
connect with the younger audience and
they're going to places like this the
other day she did another podcast with
somebody young I don't know who it was
but anyways I think she's campaigning
right now look at the next one hundred
percent are you kidding me this is a
dream of us to be a president hard pass
online they pay you how much they pay
you well now we know more about you Kim
no pizza Kim did you ask the uh pan suit
what happened to those 33 000 emails
again going back to it you would think
50 would support it exactly right but a
hundred percent doesn't look at the
likes they're getting on the comments
too exactly two thousand five thousand
three thousand so what do you think
about this when you when you see this is
this a is this a who wins here does
Hillary and Chelsea when you're does Kim
Kardashian win here they all lose they
all lose that's like me and keep sitting
down with Mitt Romney or dick change you
wouldn't do it hell no they could pay me
10 million dollars come on Champion all
three of these people are tone deaf yeah
because my brand is all about your
reputations it's all about what you did
in your last video you could lose that
like that I have an idea on why I think
she did this yeah I have no idea so okay
now stay with me here she was just on
The Late Late Show with Corydon James
Corden right and she said you know if if
I'm gonna be back in the dating you know
scene I want to date a lawyer or a
scientist or something like that and by
the way I'm actually a fan of hers I
think she's you know their family are
great marketers they know how to tell
the story and all this other stuff right
of course the way you know everyone
knows the story the video all that stuff
but go back to the go back to the
picture go back to the picture here's
here's what maybe let's speculate who
did she just get a divorce from Kanye
and who would he would Kanye ever do a
podcast with Hillary and Chelsea there
you go if Kanye was to ever do a podcast
he would do it with so you're calling
Kim a troll
um
I'm calling Kim is really trying to get
under Kanye's nerves because behind
closed doors I'm convinced Kim knows
this lady so I don't know I I may be
wrong but I think you're absolutely
right here we go that's my speculation I
was thinking the same thing when she
started dating Pete what's his name Pete
Davis yeah yeah that's like how you go
from Kanye to a comedian to Skeet yeah
yeah he got replaced by a guy named
Marcelo which is a million times
my guy oh my God so and by the way
apparently they had it they had a what
didn't didn't they have like a uh back
and forth of a lawyer what is they had a
contest Kim Kardashian beat Hillary
Clinton in a legal quiz uh their
knowledge on Law and apparently she took
him out I don't know Chelsea who acted
as the official quizzer uh first asked a
question about the use of deadly force
Kardashian busting quickly before
expecting answering the inquiry after a
few more rounds of inquiries queries we
see Kardashian beat Hillary Clinton to
buy a land Slide 11-4 the former
presidential candidate later told the
publication that it was quite the
humbling experience oh it was
heartbreaking well I was also really
intrigued by how well she did I wanted
to uh put the spotlight on her not that
she needs it but she worked really hard
okay so there's something going on there
but if you see more and more of her I
can tell you for a fact which which
podcast she's not going to be doing I
can tell you for a fact where she will
not go you ready she ain't going to Zach
down
we have to take a break for our uh what
is it our sponsor this is Donald Trump
do you remember that when the middle of
a g Place say Donald Trump I'm Donald
Trump and I endorse this message he's
like why would you do that
he's the he's the ultimate troll can you
pull up the Santa story of Yahoo what I
just said earlier I don't know if you
have it or not when I said the Santa is
about to break her record for the most
money raised
if you can find this article there watch
this year Florida Rhonda Santas on the
cusp of raising more money than any
Governor ever
okay ever see this is that's huge so
this is the talking to a guy that's you
know you're talking to a guy that
everything he did the anti-galot that
was risky the allowing people to play
that was risky there are no masks needed
that was risky they're going after the
teachers that was risky the what he did
with Disney that was risky that what he
did to remove the tax benefits of Disney
World right that was do you know how
much risk this guy has taken in the last
two two three years and every time he
keeps coming ahead I talked to a uh um
how do you describe like we can't say
the name just so you know so don't don't
say her name is this a big actress or
not the Hollywood yes how big would you
say
top 10 female actress of all time okay
so her and I are communicating with each
other and I said I'd love for you to
come to Florida okay I'd love to break
Brit and I'd love to potentially and we
follow each other's content she follows
me so I would never come to Florida
why won't you come to Florida you want
me to come to Florida to see what the
scientists did to the State of Florida
she was being real she wasn't messing
around about not wanting to come to a
place like this so to to California
Florida's like a reckless state to be in
for people who live in Florida let me
tell you people love living in Florida
okay there there is no disputing that of
course you know there's going to be some
of our friends that will Nikki fried
will come here and say there's people
that don't want to be in Florida but
there's a lot of people that love being
in the state here yeah Florida so are
you guys planning on staying where
you're at is Nevada is going to be a
place to be a long-term no let's turn
into a [ __ ] California's coming over
um we're looking at Texas or here in
Florida Florida here in Florida well if
you did come out here to Florida we
would probably do a lot of stuff
together if you came down here yeah can
I sell you on Florida for one minute
yeah so what do you like about Texas
over Florida tell me tell me the
difference between if you go to Texas
where would you go in Texas would you go
to the Cowboys but Dallas Cowboys are
you really but I mean Texas real
property taxes yeah is crazy yeah yeah
um I mean Florida's great but we're just
eating at Wendy's and this freaking
lizard came out yeah there's lizards and
it's just sitting there looking at me
yeah that's they look like a komodo
dragons
what the hell is going on they don't
attack you they don't do anything they
want us they won't do nothing
what the [ __ ] these are these are
lizards on steroids bro
and it's got all these colors right
there
these guys look scary but they're soft
they won't do nothing to you they want
to know so what why else do you like
Dallas why what else do you like about
Dallas Because by the way Dallas is both
of these YouTube's in top two okay I
would probably put Nashville in it as
well but why Dallas over Florida
um well it's like 50 50 right now you
guys 50 50 right it's not one or the
other yeah my wife loves that was almost
a deal breaker until you explain it
how do people live in Florida they got
Komodo dragons
I lived in L.A for 20 some years really
minus the time I was in the military I
was in Kentucky Tennessee South Carolina
and then we moved uh the insurance
company to Dallas Texas and it was in
Addison Texas still till today it's in
Addison Texas I lived there for five
years in Plano it's a great City kids
went to school they're phenomenal uh
place to live in but then to me there's
a lot of parts of California I love
there's a lot of parts of Texas I love
in California and Texas were to have a
baby it would be Florida okay yeah so
Florida has the best of both Best of
Both Worlds of those two places right uh
if you want to do the you know water if
you want to do the ocean if you want to
go on the boat if you want to go big
Sports Town big you know uh it start to
get a massive Hub in Miami where people
business people are moving down here
obviously got the best Governor right
now that's in down doing what he's doing
and Texas is a bigger Target for folks
from the left and Florida so this the
scientist is gradually recruiting a lot
of people so I've been telling a lot of
friends that you know went to Texas I
said it's a pit stop dude don't worry
about it about two to five years to be
down here because you'll see what's
going to be happening so but if you guys
do come down here man we'll be doing
some stuff together yeah Florida is a
very very different type of a place I
love Texas I love California but I'm in
love with Florida hopefully it'll stay
this way anyways okay so let's see what
else we got here before we wrap this up
because this is so far been a blast so
um
I got two comedians here so I wanna so
let's do this let me do this well why
don't we just play this part though why
don't we just play this part okay
her estate okay her estate the rest and
peace what she did okay and who she was
to the country but I never understand
that whole King between how do they earn
their money how do they earn their money
yeah generational wealth tax-free this
is a true generational wealth yeah but
how who decided they was going to be
king and queen it's just that's the
structure of it the most destruction
that's the monarchy so Iran used to be
like this so the you know sometimes
people don't like the fact that they're
too rich and they have too much money
which is a very valid point because they
can say why do you need to have so much
money so for example okay they talked
about our stamp collection how much you
think her stamp collection is worth
stamp collection okay so stupid about
500.
[Laughter]
stamp collection just take a wild guess
well I say 1200 cause inflation you know
okay 1200 bucks instead of 500 I would
just say uh stamp collection over under
10 million dollars okay 136 million
dollars what stuff is the stamp card
was a little low stamp collection 136
million dollars okay yes stamps stamps
she was saving stamps dude she has a
stamp collection of 136 million dollars
next one how much was her real estate
portfolio by the time she passed away oh
man real estate portfolio she got 136
million dollars you better go north of
that come on give me a number give me a
number what do you think I could come
over the number that damn High 100
million how much 400 I'm gonna I'm gonna
show it to him and look at his facial
reaction when he sees this
that's crazy 10 billion dollars
real estate I'm not even kidding with
you 10 billion 10 billion car collection
a hundred million dollars okay yes car
collection 100 stamps is worth more than
the cars yes car collection 100 million
horse racing 10 million you know their
art collection which was 270 000 items
seven thousand paintings 30 000
watercolors and drawings as well as
manuscripts of sculptures uh tapestry
furniture and carriages how much you
think the art collection is
you ready 13 billion dollars and last
but not least this
she wore this a few times I don't know
if you guys remember when she wore this
okay Crown Jewel it's called The Crown
Jewel can you pull up the crown jewels
just pull up the picture of the crown
jewels not the price just the crown
jewels okay crown jewels right there
that's the one right there just click on
images okay crown jewels what would you
say that is worth
I want you to actually guess it's like
you got out of like a gumball machine
Party City 500 million dollars 500
million dollars what are you gonna say
Keith I'll go with 500 million [ __ ] it
I'll go back
I figured you'd go 501.
5 billion for that stop five billion for
that you could get that at Party City
five billion dollars that's crazy you
know what I don't believe in White
Privilege but if White Privilege did
exist this is it yeah I mean this is
like on a whole different level thank
you for uh tying it all together
they don't pay no taxes on this five
billion I mean I mean how did he earn
that money like taxes from other people
I couldn't tell you I I you know you
guys should know you guys were former
accountants
that's the kind of stuff you guys do you
should tell us I'm Gonna Be a King man I
hate to say this don't just look like he
got kids in this basement man
Prince Albert is I think is a thing you
do a different type of earring on
prince Andrew might have been with those
kids I'd never understood how they
generated generated that much wealth
like what are you talking about the
English Empire the British Empire what
are you talking about
which is called colonizing the [ __ ]
world oh okay how the hell do you what
they so they have businesses yeah just
stealing [ __ ] from other countries
raping India raping other guy what
I don't get that I I don't understand
why any society would need a king and a
queen it's funny how um they kept
calling Trump like he thinks he's a king
he's no King he named his son Baron he's
no burn and look and then the left they
just praise this woman and all this
wealth and yeah but
Kanye West what do you think about it
oh he seems like a good fella
the most diplomatic non-answer ever he's
a nice guy
um it took a lot of balls for a black
man especially with his reputation in
the music industry in Hollywood to go
see Donald Trump the most hated
supposedly be a white supremacy he went
there and he didn't he cut through all
the [ __ ] and he said I'm gonna go
see him anyway yeah I mean he's
definitely a leader he's not a follower
by any strict then Steve Harvey go to
that same meeting I think Steve Harvey
got him he's bored as well oh yeah yeah
black person go see Trump oh you are a
traitor they lamb based they did his Ice
Cube too why do you ask about Kanye pet
curious because for me I mean look I'd
love to sit down with Connie have a
really long conversation with him
because I think he is another one of
those guys that's misunderstood and the
quote goes if a lion could speak we
could not understand him there's certain
people that are lines that the average
person cannot understand that someone
needs to be able to get him to explain
it in a way layman's terms would make
sense to people but the guy yeah he's
he's not he's not a regular guy he
doesn't look he has a very different
lens on yeah he got other people for
that one quote about slavery but you
know a lot of things that he say
um can be taken out of context and and
you know twisted around especially
because he speaks in you know metaphors
and analogies you need to get like when
you sit down and talk to him when he
says something you got to have him
clarify what he just stated because he
is a deep thinker I think his next level
musical genius no doubt I also think
he's a tortured soul I mean he's gone
through a lot of mental stuff anxiety
stuff depression stuff and his mom and
stuff everything that that guy's dealing
with there's no clearance answer
freaking a Kardashian too they can't be
[ __ ] easy that cannot be good on your
mental health Christ is it true you guys
had a little bit of a meltdown uh
recently when news came out that they
moved Don Lemon away from prime time oh
yeah it came out it was kind of limited
hard I heard you guys took it very
they put in this position I still have
material but
I mean these all these people that was
on I mean the everybody at CNN is
getting fired or being demoted and it's
like yeah everybody that's a good thing
maybe yeah I think it's a very good
thing because a lot of the a lot of the
um the hosting commentators they had on
those networks they've lost a lot of
credibility because how long can you
keep saying that he's uh guys a white
supremacist that he colluded with Russia
that he did this did that and then over
time nothing ever materializes and it's
like yeah you guys just a bunch of liars
yeah but they were just the face of it
the high-ups was telling them everything
to say everything was on the
teleprompter for them they had a message
for them and they had to stick with and
then when it didn't go wrong they fired
them because that whole reputation
starts because it's coming out of my
mouth I mean until you just dismantle
CNN and start with new ownership that
that place is dead for me yeah it's not
even necessarily um against Don Lemon
and that other guy this ball Brian
Selter yeah he was just reading
teleprompters he was just being told
what to say and how to say it yeah I
mean it's not necessarily his fault that
you know but I mean you you the figure
of that organization and that broadcast
so whatever you say people are going to
automatically assume that hey you're the
producer you're the writer of this show
everything that's coming out of your
mouth you approve of it so yeah
if it didn't work I think I think it's
this is just a paycheck for them so yeah
they were sacrifices but but again but
but you know but you know how I process
that here's how I process that Adam this
kind of goes to your question earlier
about the whole vote the way I processed
this is is if you don't if you start
pushing the envelope to the point where
you make no sense and you're just
gaslighting people right customers are
going to say yeah we're not about this
man change it up we're not dummies you
got to figure something out and CNN is
now having to change their entire
business model because it's not working
right it's just not working people are
not interested in you gaslighting me 24
7 so change it up or else I'm going
elsewhere and then CNN's going to be
bought by somebody for pennies on a
dollar like other businesses will go
through so this whole thing with Trump
being rated if they don't indict him or
they find anything good on him these
MSNBC CNN they're going to lose a lot
more credibility because they just rated
it was the first time they ever occurred
where the FBI rated a former president's
house I'm surprised Morning Joe is to
taking such a hard I mean I understand
when Trump went after his co-host uh his
wife you know his wife I totally get it
and when he goes and he said what he
said about him but I saw her she got a
face lift her face was cut and bleeding
and he goes personal attacks and that's
why they're they're yeah it's an
emotional argument he does what they do
to him right he does what they do to him
and they don't like you know it's kind
of like a guy that likes to put it on
others but doesn't like to receive it
Democrats love to you but if you come
back to them and play their game they
don't they don't appreciate it
was a representative from Florida
Republican conservative Tea Party Guy no
question about it he's no longer uh
Republican it's very very hard it's very
very hard for one to give their this was
give their you know you know what they
lean in a situation that's coming up in
a logical way when somebody goes after
your family it's very hard to do that so
no matter who you are whether it's Megan
McCain when Trump went after you know it
doesn't matter what it is at that point
loyalty is about blood you know who is
cool going after each other's family
though these two Knuckleheads they go
back and forth no problem Keith Kevin
they'll fight with each other but I dare
anybody try to divide these guys you
would not want to get in between these
guys can I make one last Point yeah you
two guys talking the concept of
Brotherhood we just sat down with Tate
his best friend is his brother Tristan
they're going nowhere you look at Logan
and Jake I'm looking at you guys I mean
this I have a sister I wish that I had a
brother there's something to be said
about having someone that thinks ax
feels just like you and that has your
back I mean nobody has what we have yeah
not the ones Brothers not anybody
Wayne's Brothers how do you break that
down what do you mean I mean me and
Keith I mean you don't see The Williams
Brothers doing anything together that
brand was solid man he had that hit TV
show they had white chicks but you don't
never see them together yeah they can't
be too close maybe maybe who knows yeah
so what's the methodology with being
brothers and being twins it's like we're
gonna do I don't know we are unicorns we
are very unique because a lot of twins
when they're born
a lot of them hate each other one ends
up trying to kill the others can't ruin
the other person's hands you know what
it is a lot of them they're in
competition with one another yeah me and
my brother's never been in competition
when he was doing bigger and better
things like doing the spelling bee and
all that
you say you know what man he was on
sixth grade when you were killing and
that's
he was on honor roll yeah I wasn't doing
none of that I was doing anything you
were rooting for him no I didn't care I
thought he was waxed
so but you know over time you know you
we just came closing because we are
we've been close yeah yeah I think I
used to help you in the spelling bee
right
shut up
Almanac Almanac
a-l-m-a-n-a-c oh my god
oh man it's a bummer man you really
tried real hard this time I thought he's
misspelled it because I wanted to say
this delivery you in the room with them
when they did that yeah I was right
there yeah
it was at school in the middle of the
day everybody everybody this school is
in the auditorium we having a spelling
bee this is a big deal this is big time
right it's about 150 kids in there yeah
man I was up and I see my dad in the
crowd my mom I was like nervous man that
was that was big time
I made it to the top and I made it all
the way to the last two yeah and then
they came to me I said oh I'm like oh I
got this one hopefully he don't get his
I've already got this by the way that's
a great name for a book
okay people can be like why all men like
you're like let me tell you the story
about Almanac and what happened and how
my life got started and where I am now
but anyways man this was uh incredible
uh the audience obviously loved it uh
having you guys on it's no surprise you
guys are entertaining the world on a
regular basis uh gang if you haven't yet
subscribed to their channel can we make
sure we put the channel both in the chat
as well as the description for people to
find it any projects you guys are
working on right now that you want
people any any major projects you're
working on right now that you want to
tell the audience
um
um don't have really don't have [ __ ]
going on but not right now we're going
tour right now you can come see us live
at hodgetwinsstore.com but
um we on YouTube at conservative twins
yeah we start another
um YouTube channel we call it Patriot
twins well you know it's it's a little
less political this is our politics
coming to play but it's more about
current events yeah so more about
current events let's put both of those
links below uh gang again are we doing
podcasts tomorrow tomorrow Kevin Sorbo
Kevin Sorbo is tomorrow podcast
fantastic please Hercules we will see
you guys tomorrow on the podcast fellas
thanks so much for coming on man this
was blessed for having me absolutely
take care everybody